AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> ♪ ♪
>> IT'S BEEN THE BURNING
QUESTION.
WILL PRESIDENT TRUMP ATTEND THE
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENCE
DINNER AT THE END OF THE MONTH?
HE DIDN'T GO LAST YEAR BECAUSE
OF HIS FEUD WITH THE PRESS.
>> I DID THE GRID IRON DINNER A
FEW WEEKS AGO.
THAT WAS TERRIFIC.
WE HAD FUN AND IT WAS GOOD.
I FEEL THAT THE PRESS IS SO BAD
AND SO FAKE, IT'S SO MADE UP.
I MEAN SOURCES SAY AND THEY HAVE
NO SOURCES.
THEY ARE LIKE NOVELISTS.
THEY MAKEUP THE SOURCES.
SOME SOME CASES THERE ARE
SOURCES BUT THEY WON'T DO IT
CORRECTLY.
IN MANY CASES THEY LITERALLY
MAKEUP SOURCES.
9 SOURCES WITHIN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THERE ARE NO 9 SOURCES.
I WANT TO GET IT SORTED OUT WITH
THE PRESS.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE SAID SARAH
SANDERS WILL GO IN TRUMP'S
PLACE.
DID THE PRESIDENT MAKE THE RIGHT
MOVE CONSIDERING HOW THE PRESS
TREATS HIM?
HERE ARE A FEW OF THE LATEST
EXAMPLES.
>> INSTEAD OF TRUMP MAKING
BIZARRE FALSE CLAIMS, YOU CAN
SAY TRUMP LIES AND JUST PUT
AGAIN ABOUT ILLEGAL VOTING?
>> HE IS AS DISMISS OF TRUTH AS
HE IS OF ETHICES.
IT WORKS UP TO A POINT.
I AM SAD TO SAY IT CAN LEAD TO
THE DIMINISHMENT OF DEMOCRACY IF
NOT IT'S DEATH.
>> HERE IS THE LUBRICANT OF
TRUMPISM.
SMALL, PETTY, CRUEL, MEAN
SPIRITED FEAR.
>> FEAR IS THE LUBRICANT OF
DICTATORS.
>> YOU COULD PUT A WHOLE HOUR OF
THIS AND WE WOULD NEVER GET
ENOUGH OF IT.
COME ON!
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS?
>> GOOD OR BAD DECISION?
>> FEAR IS THE LUBRICANT IS
STUCK IN MY BRAIN.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I THINK IT'S A GOOD DECISION.
I HAVE BEEN TO THESE DINNERS.
IT'S FAKER THAN THE SCENERY IN
THE "SOUND OF MUSIC."
THEY SAY IT'S A GOOD CAUSE.
BUT IT'S PATHETIC.
THERE ARE TWO GROUPS.
THERE ARE THE PRESS AND THE
CELEBRITIES THAT THE PRESS
INVITES.
THE CELEBRITIES WANDER AROUND
THE AUDITORIUM LIKE COOL KIDS AT
AN UGLY FARM WHICH IT IS.
THE PRESS INDULGESES THE
CELEBRITIES CLIMBING OVER EACH
OTHER FOR SELFIES.
IT'S EMBARRASSING BECAUSE TO SEE
GROWN MEN AND WOMEN ACTING
STUPID BECAUSE THAT PERSON IS IN
THAT SIT-COM.
THE DINNER IS SATURDAY NIGHT.
IF DONALD TRUMP IS NOT GOING, I
AM HOPING MY SHOW, THE GREG
GUTFELD SHOW IS NOT COVERING IT
LIVE.
IT'S THE MOST TEDIOUS WASTE OF
TIME I COULD IMAGINE.
WE COULD COUNTER-PROGRAM.
DO SOMETHING MORE FUN.
MAYBE HAVE DONALD TRUMP ON.
>> I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT.
I AGREE WITH YOU 100%.
NO REASON THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
GO TO THIS.
SYCOPHANTS SERVING SYCOPHANTS.
THEY RUN AGAINST HIM BUT WANT TO
BASK IN HIS GLOW TO MOCK HIM.
TREVOR NOAH IS HOSTING IT.
CNN IS GETTING AN AWARD FOR
FANTASTIC JOURNAL AND SO IS NBC
AND THE "NEW YORK TIMES," THE
FAILING "NEW YORK TIMES" MAGGIE
IS GET AN AWARD.
>> I THINK IT'S A WRITER FROM
THE "DAILY SHOW."
>> YES.
>> EQUALLY FAIR AND
ENTERTAINING.
>> THE EMBODIMENT OF EVERYTHING
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAMPAIGNED
AGAINST.
THIS IS THE SWAMP.
I LOVE WHAT HE DID LAST YEAR
DURING THE NIGHT OF THE DINNER
AND HELD A RALLY IN HARRISBURG,
PENNSYLVANIA.
I HOPE HE DOES THE SAME THING IN
WISCONSIN OR OHIO AND SAY YOU
ARE THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN.
ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE
PART OF THE SWAMP ARE IN D.C.
SCHMUCKING IT UP.
I THINK IT'S SMART.
I THINK HE SHOULD HIT THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL LIKE HE DID LAST
YEAR.
>> JUAN, WHAT ELSE COULD HE DO
THAT WOULD DELIGHT AND ENTHRALL
YOU?
>> HE COULD STEP DOWN.
>> THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> RIGHT.
>> WHAT WOULD WE DO FOR RATINGS?
>> WE HAVE HILLARY CLINTON.
>> THAT'S A GOT POINT.
YOU GUYS SEEM TO TAKE A ONE
SIDED VIEW OF THIS.
I THINK DONALD TRUMP SAID THE
PRESS IS THE ENEMY OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> FAKE NEWS.
TRUMP SAID FAKE NEWS IS THE
ENEMY OF THE PEOPLE.
OF THESE BITES WE PLAYED AT THE
TOP OF THE SHOW, PEOPLE ARE
COMPLAINING ABOUT SOMETHING
LEGITIMATE.
HE SAID ALL OF THESE IMMIGRANT
WOMEN ARE GETTING RAPED.
>> THEY ARE.
>> HE SAID THERE WERE SO MANY
ILLEGAL FRAUDULENT VOTES IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
HE HAS NO EVIDENCE OF.
THIS THE PRESS POINTS IT OUT AND
YOU SAY THERE GOES THE PRESS
AGAIN.
>> IT'S NOT JUST DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S CBS'S JOHN DICKERSON, THEY
ILLEGITEMMIZE THEMSELVES.
THEY DAMAGED THEIR ONLY
REPUTATION.
>> WE MAKE MISTAKES.
THAT'S TRUE OF EVERY PRESIDENT.
TO MY MIND.
I HAVE BEEN TO EVERY ONE OF THEM
SINCE 1980.
THE ONLY PRESIDENT THAT MISSED
WAS RONALD REAGAN AFTER HE WAS
SHOT.
YOU PUT IT DOWN.
IN REALITY IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE OFTEN IN
DIRECT CONFLICT, THE KIND OF
PRESS VERSUS POWERFUL PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHY HE WENT TO THE GRID
IRON DINNER THAT WAS MORE
EXCLUSIVE AND ELITE.
THAT WAS NOT TELEVISED.
THIS IS TELEVISED.
THIS IS FAR MORE DEMOCRATIC THAN
THE GRID IRON DINNER.
>> WELL, ALL I KNOW, I GO BY OWN
EXPERIENCE BEING THERE.
IT'S A SWEATY, PATHETIC, HUDDLE
OF WANNA BE CELEBRITIES UP
AGAINST CELEBRITIES.
THE IDEA OF SITTING AT HOME
WATCHING A DINNER WHEN YOU COULD
BE WATCHING SOMETHING REAL, LIKE
THE GREG GUTFELD SHOW.
OR JESSE'S SHOW OR JUDGE.
I AM PLUGGING FOR SATURDAY
NIGHT.
>> EXACTLY.
>> IT'S A HUDDLE OF
SELF-IMPORTANCE PEOPLE THAT
BELIEVE THEY ARE SAVING THE
REPUBLIC FROM DONALD TRUMP.
IF YOU WATCH THE WAY THIS DINNER
WENT THROUGH 8 YEARS OF BARACK
OBAMA, HE MAY HAVE ATTENDED IT,
BUT HE WAS ATTENDED A CHORUS OF
CLAPPING SEALS WHO WERE PROP
GATING HIS ADMINISTRATION FOR 8
YEARS.
TO THINK THAT DONALD TRUMP WOULD
NOT BE SMEARED IS FANTASY TALK.
HE IS A SEE SOMETHING AND SAY
SOMETHING PRESIDENT.
YOU TALK ABOUT ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT ASPECTS.
HE IDENTIFIES LAWLESSNESS ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND THE PRESS 56
IT APART.
>> YOU BRING UP A GREAT POINT.
THE PRESS IS VERY UNFAIR TO THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY WILL NOT GIVE CREDIT TO HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND NATIONAL
SECURITY AND THE ECONOMY AND
IMMIGRATION.
HOW HE DEREGULATED AND GOT RID
OF SOME OF THE PROBLEMS IN THE
ECONOMY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO ADMIT ANY OF
THIS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO GIVE HIM
CREDIT FOR ANYTHING HE'S DONE.
THAT CAUSED THIS RELATIONSHIP TO
BE THE WAY IT IS.
>> YOU MEAN ANN COULTER.
SHE IS ATTACKING HIM FROM THE
RIGHT.
WHEN PEOPLE SAY YOU DON'T
DELIVER ON THE WALL AND
MR. PRESIDENT YOU ARE A
REPUBLICAN, DON'T WE BELIEVE IN
FREE-TRADE?
WE ARE NOT HAVING A TRADE WAR.
THE NEXT MORNING MORE PENALTIES
ON CHINA AND MORE TRADE WAR.
>> THERE IS AN EVENING OF THE
SCALES.
>> OH, I SEE!
>> NOTHING HAS HAPPENED.
THEY ARE JUST TALKING ABOUT IT.
THE OBVIOUS THING HERE:
HE IS NOT GOING BECAUSE HE IS
SMART.
YOU DON'T GO TO A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE WILL INSULT YOU FOR 2 OR
3 HOURS.
>> YOUR POINT EARLIER, THEY
WOULD KISS HIS BUTT.
>> REALLY.
>> HE IS THE PRESIDENT.
THEY ALWAYS HONOR THE OFFICE OF
PRESIDENT.
THEY WANT HIM TO COME?
>> THEY HONOR THE WAS OF
PRESIDENT.
HAVE YOU BEEN LOOKING AT THE
HEADLINES?
>> CNN IS GETTING AN AWARD FOR
THEIR COVERAGE OF RUSSIA.
>> RIGHT.
>> HAVE YOU WATCHED CNN AND
THEIR COVERAGE OF RUSSIA?
IT'S THE MOST ONE SIDED SLANTED
ASSAULT ON THIS PRESIDENT.
>> THEY GET THE AWARD FOR
MANUFACTURING FAKE NEWS.
>> THE "NEW YORK TIMES" HAD AN
EDITORIAL THIS MORNING.
WE HAVE TO SEE THE LARGER
THINGS.